so let's have a look at this question
and let's just read the whole thing
sometimes where you need to start is all
the way at the end or in the middle of
the question so let's taking the whole
object okay it says given that the
derivative of f of X is and then they
give you a function given that the
derivative of f of X is that and F of 1
equals 1 and 1/2 find f of X okay so
you've got all of the pieces of the
question sort of circulating around your
head at the moment have you noticed that
in calculus we are taking all the
strands that you have built up over like
the last 11 years
we're taking arithmetic and algebra
we're taking function notation we're
taking log laws and index laws and we're
Shammi it all together I've said this a
few times before to my class last year
but calculus is kind of what most of K
to 10 has somewhat been building towards
which is disappointing because a lot of
people don't end up doing calculus and
so they never find out like it's like
reading the first six books in Harry
Potter and then just saying yeah
definitely Hallows don't worry about I
don't have time that it's like but we've
been waiting six books of this please
note how important all those foundation
blocks are when you get your ap 3s which
will not be long believe me often the
areas that you make all the marks you
lose and not the new stuff you've learnt
there on the old stuff okay so we had
this f of X the question is to find what
f of X is they give us some information
that's sort of around f of X which will
enable us to get to there the first
piece of information they give you is a
derivative right so they say that f dash
is equal to and then there's this object
let's write that down
I think it's x squared plus X plus 1 is
that right
divided by X yep f - yep so the
derivative of F so I'm using my notation
here right the derivative of f there it
is is this okay now think about this and
this is probably worth o my colors he's
probably worth riding on the side just
as a reminder for you right if you have
f of X and you have f
- right the way to get back and forth
between these is by two processes that
we know to get to f of X from F what do
you do what's it called it's called it's
early in the morning isn't it and we
haven't had much sleep
it's called differentiation we've made
this point it's not called deriving even
who you end up with a derivative we
differentiate to get from F to F - but
to get back to F like so how do we do
this how do we reverse the process
what's it called it's called integration
right so when you have a look at what
you have and what you need to get to
clearly that's why integration will be
involved they don't tell you integrate
blah blah blah right you have to work
that out yourself through your knowledge
of how F and F dash are related okay
good now do you remember I showed you an
example like this I think this is
something like what it was hmm I can't
remember the numbers I feel like that
was something else I showed you an
example like this and I said hey if you
get asked to differentiate this then of
course if you had a death wish you could
do the quotient rule right away because
it is a question but I encourage you not
to do that what did I encourage you to
do first
instead I encourage you to simplify why
is that why not just go to the question
rule we know a question rule why not use
it because we don't like it let's be
more specific why do we dislike the
question rule it is long and messy and
error-prone so simplifying first is a
good habit to get into
before you differentiate the same is
also true of integration okay if you
look at an object that you think I can
simplify this first then do that and
that might make your integration easier
what might be an obvious thing to do in
this case
yeah actually divide through it's
written as a quotient as one single
object but I can write it as three
separate ones x squared divided by X is
X X divided by X is one and then you
just get one an exhale on the end which
is
why hopefully your brain is Sakura why
this question is in this exercise yeah
okay so this is f - I've already
established to get back to F I'm gonna
have to integrate so let's do that now
my next line is f of X I'm integrating
both sides integral of all of this stuff
with respect to X that okay please note
the way that I'm setting this out okay
this is one continuous line of argument
one continuous line of logic okay
started with the derivative rearrange
the derivative integrating the
derivative to come back to the original
function this is f of X you can help me
out now we've sort of done most of the
the logical legwork I just now have to
integrate this thing right X is going to
become 1/2 x squared or x squared on to
what about the 1 it becomes just X and
then what about this guy this is the
thing we've been focusing on most
recently this is what turns into the log
now this is an indefinite integral so
I'm missing one more thing let me see
your constant this is f of X now at this
point you have found f of X which was
sort of the question okay but I want you
to look back at the question again as a
piece of information they've given to us
that we can use to go a little bit
further okay started four years of drama
and in drama we learn about this thing
called Chekhov's gun Chekhov was a um a
Russian playwright
he said if you've got a gun on the stage
in act 1 then it must fire by act 3 you
don't put things there by accident and
everything in a question in a textbook
or an exam is like Chekhov's gun what's
the extra piece of information the extra
piece of information is this yeah do you
see it there I haven't touched at all
right so I'm suspicious that they put it
there and I'm like I haven't used it how
will this be useful F of 1 is 1 and a
half so there's a value right that comes
from substituting in that value 1 into
all the spots where X is so let's see
what happens if I actually make use of
this fact here if I substitute in 1 I
get what can you tell me what I get
I get a half out the front I get one I
get I'm gonna write log of one I just
I'll come to it in a second so I do the
substitution and then C is still hanging
out over here because it is independent
of X so it's still C okay now I can
simplify some of this before I do that I
just want to note that I know what f of
1 is equal to because they told me right
so on the left hand side again please
note the line of logic and how clearly
you can follow it this I know to be 1
and a half because it's given right so
now I can tidy all of this up on the
right hand side that's one and a half as
well so said that's zero yes so one and
a half plus C so you can see and this is
quite a common thing you want to be able
to find not just that there is a
constant but what is that constant if
you get given sufficient information
then you can determine its value in this
case C of course is just equal to just
zero so I'm ready to conclude now okay I
can say therefore f of X equals and I
have it here but now I can actually tell
you what C is by the way C is very
frequently zero but it obviously doesn't
have to be zero like if I change this to
two or negative 1 or PI this would end
up being a different number over here
yes so I might get something else out in
this case I just get x squared on 2 plus
X plus log enters and I'm done okay so
do you see what I mean
you possessed all the knowledge to do
this before I showed you this example
because what knowledge did you need you
need to know that integration is the
relationship between these you need to
know how to integrate teeny bit of
algebraic manipulation and then some
substitution you have all that knowledge
already ok but stringing it all together
you're like wow you had to pick up on
all those things without anyone telling
you part 1 part 2 part 3 you had to make
up the part 1 part 2 part 3 yourself
okay